i gotta ask you were you how nervous
were you for your debut stream because
i assume you didn't have any streaming
experience before that
and then going from going from like no
streaming experience like stream to
such a large how many people were in
your debut stream again i think that the
peak number of viewers was sixty
thousand jesus christ
holy [ __ ] that's going from zero to 60k
in a day i mean i've i mean i think we
all had like kind of i don't think we've
never reached yeah we've never reached
those numbers in live streaming right
right i mean i've had like live streams
that were big but nothing like that and
especially not my first time is it kind
of overwhelming to have to jump into
this and
start off with such a big amount because
like i said we've all had really gradual
rises over the years
right is it daunting even as a death god
right well see here's the thing when
you're deaf uh no one really sees you
right yes i mean for the most part maybe
you do see me but not as i
think there's people you kill and doom
see it coming from
well i wouldn't
exactly well i mean if you think about
it that way
going from yes no one ever seeing me at
all to suddenly
all of these eyes on me yeah i mean it's
a little scary
yeah for sure i definitely was kind of
losing my mind a little bit
to be honest uh i was going a little
nuts though uh but i wasn't gonna show
anyone that especially not when um
when i started turning into a powerpoint
slideshow because my computer wasn't
strong enough to handle
all the applications open at the same
time that's when i especially started
freaking out
um so yeah it was very nerve-wracking
but uh people were very kind and i was
surprised about that i was
i went in expecting an immediate barrage
of hate and um
and no kindness at all believe it or not
because that is the internet that is
yeah
yeah pretty good that's death i'm
prepared i'm prepared for that
yeah i mean oh that's good though that
you were at least you know positively
received in front of 60
000 people yeah so what made death want
to become a streamer that's
that's what i wanted what a great
question
sometimes you just you just get tired of
slaying people man i tell you what
i mean i feel like i'm asking dora why
she keeps asking me questions
you know i mean it's like i know it's an
obvious thing but like why do you keep
exploring
what's up with that like there's nothing
more left to actually you know what that
is
it's the number four dora don't ask me
these super questions
you know you have to turn left
all right
yeah so um i really just kind of got
i mean as i mentioned yeah i got tired
of slaying people but also i had this
feeling that maybe
if i had more eyes on i could have more
eyes on maybe the things that i make
right like music
because slaying people is real fun don't
get me wrong i love it
but but spitting balls is fun right
exactly
if there's a different way that i can
slay people i'd like to try it
and honestly i have more fun doing that
so yeah you kill people by setting their
house on fire right with all those
flames
exactly lyrical slain